alright guys by now you've heard the
rumors you read the reports and you've
seen the tribute videos zip --ax and
glaive for the moment anyway are out of
a straw 'less and there sudden medical
leaves of absence came as a shocking
surprise to a lot of us in their place
are a group of former heroic players two
of which are gonna stay on full-time in
a straw list to form some kind of seven
man roster I got questions a lot of
questions and to get the answers I went
right to a straw Louis and talked to a
few key people in the organization
namely their sports psychologist and
their sports director strap in
fullscreen this video and get ready
because we're going deep on this one all
right before we go any further guys if
you didn't know already we are streaming
on the regular these days so head on
over to twitch.tv slash the score
eSports and give us a follow and turn
those notifications on I promise you
won't be sorry and if you haven't subbed
to this YouTube channel yet come on what
are you waiting for them alright so this
all started about a month ago when the
in-game leader for the best csgo team of
all time announced he was leaving not
for good but for three months due to
stress and burnout basically glaive went
on medical leave this announcement came
by the way right after winning a pretty
important ESL road to Rio event now
about a week after that zip --ax the man
they call the clutch Minister a key part
of a straw las' since day one announced
he too was going on medical leave except
his didn't have a time limit attached to
it now in glaives case it all seemed
pretty planned I mean it happened right
after a big tournament not right before
one or god forbid during one and they
already had you he lined up to replace
him okay now with zip --ax things felt a
little different his leave of absence
felt more like a domino effect that came
as a result of glaives I mean s attack
wasn't able to join the team yet they
had sonic force to stand in and a
strongest seem to be scrambling to find
a replacement who they eventually did in
snappy their temporary stand-in and so
in the span of just nine days the
greatest csgo team to ever play the game
the number one ranked squad in the world
as of May was without two of its star
players and people were shocked
understandably there were and continue
to be just so many questions about these
events people were asking themselves
what's really going on here I mean they
can't both just be on medical leave
right why now why these two who's next
how are they gonna earn enough major
qualifier points if they keep swapping
people in and out why would a strongest
group announce reduced operating costs
and then turn around and sign two new
players is the seven man roster really
just some kind of smokescreen
distraction for something going on
within the astrologer organization well
zip ik sever comeback will glaze these
are just a few of the questions that you
would see flying around Twitter and
reddit and places like that and
everybody in anybody was speculating on
what was happening
including us and according to Nell
Australis also reached out allegedly to
Alex on vitality to have him jump into a
straw list so all of this together tells
me that this situation is not exactly
planned there were reports first from
Jarek DK Lewis writing for double tap
and then most recently from Richard
Lewis writing for Dex cierto that all
might not be as it seemed
with these roster moves contained in
those reports were allegations from
unnamed sources regarding friction
between astrology and players on the
subject of vacation time and breaks as
well as potential ulterior motives for
zip excessive among other things from an
outsider looking in perspective it's
hard to know what to think when you read
stuff like this so I went to a straw
Louis to ask some key people what's
really going on behind the scenes
specifically I talked to astrologist
sports psychologist Lars robble who has
worked with elite traditional sports
athletes and has a long background in
the Danish Special Forces and Kasper vet
who is the sports director for Astralis
and himself a former elite handball
athlete let's start with one of the most
basic questions about this whole
situation
is the reason that glaive and zip ik's
going on leave entirely because of
stress and burnout or are there any
their ulterior motives or reasons behind
that when I asked
Lars Robel that's the sports
psychologist that question he was very
clear on the answer the reason why we
had the guys on leave is it's because is
that there's a need for it
that's not based on any tactics or
thoughts behind it it's because they
doesn't report okay so now that glaive
and zip X are on leave there's another
question that's been making the rounds
in reddit in twitter threads you name it
and that is are they actually going to
come back to astralis well when I asked
a straw sports director Kasper did that
question he did not mince words but I
don't care about people what they think
I care about my players and I care about
astrology and our possibilities to be a
top team both today and in the future
this is not an unknown disease burnout
and stress is something everybody many
people have experienced and of course
there is a treatment and of course we
want them in the roster but when are
they coming back exactly for Glee that's
been stated about three months from the
time he left but what about zip --ax
well according to rubble putting a hard
deadline on this kind of thing can
actually be counterproductive it can add
an additional stressor to an already
burnt-out athlete now when they do come
back Kasper vid that's the sports
director for all's told me they're going
to retain essa tog and Yugi to add depth
to the roster for the long term I mean
really long time but I believe I have
the strongest counter-strike team ever I
should be really stupid to throw away
some of them I want to have this roster
with the substitutes and with the wider
roster the next 10 years and I don't see
why not
I know I'm able to do it if we take care
of the players in fact astralis has
already come out publicly and said they
want a 10 man roster now Vic told me not
to hold my breath for that being
implemented anytime
the near future but from a stralla
suspect 'iv the idea is clear to give
the players a chance to breathe and that
is what I'm trying to secure here and
that is what I am talking about in that
block and what I am hoping for that
everybody can see okay this actually
makes it kind of a sense I'm a former
pro athlete 20 years I've played
professional handball and we have more
players that we have positions on the
field because it's needed nobody and I
mean nobody
I a believer live 24/7 365 where you
don't have an option to have a break
it's not fair to the players and it's
not fair to the ox either
that we can plan I think the way the
teams are built right now it's simply
too vulnerable
I believe it's not a possibility to be
to build long term with the
vulnerability of having only five
players for five positions it's it's
actually just impossible and he did
admit that when it came to the players
on astrologist 'm wasn't necessarily an
easy sell at first but that back then
declare said now but if we had a player
then we have some some the competition
inside the group but now almost three
years later the players they know okay
we need this kind of latch of roster so
everybody I have a break and you don't
feel this responsibility that if I'm not
able to be there I am letting down all
my teammates
astralis says it's all part of the
effort on their part to transition csgo
to the next level of professionalism and
that means treating elite counter-strike
athletes like elite traditional athletes
as Robin puts it when we're talking
about sport the development and the
challenge is product layers at the
moment it's because it is based on the
fact that these athletes that we see now
on the high level I'm Travis chase or
whatever I mean they haven't had any
role models yeah
they have role models but at that time
they're all models they were competing
for a box of sodas or very few prize
money
I mean now it's it's it's it's more than
a completely different level and the
demands put on G athletes I'm much
bigger I mean they got to see themselves
as elite sport athletes but let's dial
this back to believe for just a second a
lot of people have been asking why now
why would you feel burnt out at a time
when there are less counter-strike
events than ever and there's no travel
due to kovat well as robble tells me the
discussion around glaive stress levels
it's not a new one
of course it's before we get to the
break we have had long conversations we
have tried to find solutions within the
organisation because I think it's very
very important that whatever you
whatever solutions your mind will take
it has to be taken with the apnic we
talked about okay what are the needs
what are the stressors what are the how
can we help that within the organisation
within him still play yes there was was
ups and downs but finally we had to come
to the conclusion that in order to avoid
serious burnout we had to take him out
of there out of the fight out of the
battle and just to reorganize and as
previously reported by other eSports
media outlets Rob will confirmed to me
that both glaive and zip --ax themselves
were pushing for a meaningful break from
play it was really clear saying okay no
we have tried I really need this and
then okay good then we're done
it has been bad and it's always been
also been back now speaking of zip X one
of the things that really hit me about
this situation was how unplanned zipping
Sistema compared to glaives and Vitt was
able to confirm to me that originally he
was planned to take a leave starting in
July when s attack could come in and
take over for him there were some
personal issues that suddenly happened
which made everything
having a little earlier actually the
plan was to give address or siblings the
break past 1st of July when we have use
attack coming in but with the unplanned
nature of zip Ixtapa
you got a wonder who's next could device
Majesco Dupree be dropping at wit longer
tomorrow announcing their medical leave
well according to vit that isn't the
plan but you never know what's gonna
happen in the future
you never know as just touching on with
Andreas something can happen and
actually one of the main reasons for
adding more players to the roster is is
my responsibility which is Australia
sterday within 10 days 10 months and 30
years and pay speaking of the three
other core of astralis how do they feel
about glaive and zip X taking these
leaves of absence I mean really
understand of course there is a
frustration and if you are if you're not
able to perform as you're used to
perform of course over the longer one it
will also cause some minor and I will
emphasize minor
frustration in the team of course it
will because it affects the team
performance both wobble and vit were
quick to point out to me that burnout
isn't necessarily an astrologist ring
wide problem and there is strong
evidence to support that
I mean olofmeister key RB Alex these are
all players who took a step back from
the game at the same time that glaive
and zip ik stick if you're not
performing you have this culture where
you're benched I mean and the players
know because that's a culture if you're
not if you're not performing then you're
benched and then you are off the team
and the next step is your salt so that
is that makes it difficult to fund it
for the for the players to stand up and
say okay I need a break now I'm on the
edge now and with the focus on the
mental health of players - - to step out
that's I think that's that's important I
think I think also it's important that
the other teams go along with that
all shapes of culture and if the idea is
that astrology is setting some kind of
industry-wide trend with the five plus
man roster or not every player has to go
to every tournament Vitt says that might
already be happening the day we
presented a Yakup yogi I was contacted
by one of our main competitors who told
me we want to add a six player how do
you go on with the players how do you
talk with the players how do you want to
introduce it so it's going to help but
not be a problem we have seen in so many
other games that there is an academy
team so it's easier you have a guy now
you just bring in the guy from the
Academy team this is not something we
invented our space it's something we see
in other K in other computer games
within eSports and it's something we
definitely see in traditional sport so I
think what is not logic here is that we
didn't do it before earlier and that
essentially is the astrology seven man
later ten man roster idea is a bold one
it could add some very deadly depth to
an already dangerous csgo team or at the
very least give some of these guys a
desperately needed break from the game
the early competitive results aren't
encouraging but I think it's pretty
obvious that taking away two of the core
five members of a straw at the same time
might not be the optimal way to
implement the five plus man roster but
with Rio more than five months away and
counter-strike currently stuck in this
online-only limbo meta there may not be
a better time to experiment with this
kind of stuff for me and I think for a
lot of counter-strike fans out there the
important thing in all of this is that
glaive and zip ik's fully rested to the
roster that redefine greatness in csgo
and are ready to take another shot at
immortal glory in Rio in November
we'll be watching okay this didn't make
it into the core of the video but I
couldn't let this go without getting
published in some way yeah I gotta tell
you the astrologist Lars Robin is
actually [ __ ] sick he was a
lieutenant colonel in the Danish Special
Forces he had something like six tours
in Afghanistan and that was all
obviously before he got into the sports
psychologists thing just imagine that
dude walking into your team house where
you're playing a game that simulates
terrorism counterterrorism operations
oh I'd listen to him but I remember when
I first met God God sent my first
assignment into this I didn't have a
clue about it but then they explained to
me about the the maps that were to go
and whatever they called and then I okay
and I showed them a map the photo
Afghanistan and said okay that was mine
forever and that that that create some
street credibility